chris hogan has made the initial roster
of the premier lacrosse league's boston
cannons the 2021 premier lacrosse league
season will begin this weekend from
gillette stadium on nbcsn and peacock
friday 7 p.m eastern
cannons versus the redwoods chris hogan
playing lacrosse bill belichick
undoubtedly will be on the sidelines
because he loves him peter some lacrosse
it's amazing how much belichick loves to
cross there's your full lineup for
premier lacrosse league week one all
games
are they games or matches either way all
games all contests all matches from
gillette stadium in foxborough peter but
yeah isn't it amazing
that that belichick has just such a
deep and abiding love of lacrosse
i mean i i think it's really cool that
someone who's so great at football
was also so great and smart at something
else particularly a niche sport and you
know
everybody talks about chris hogan like
he was this
sort of had a decent cup of coffee
in the nfl
and i will maintain
that the new england patriots
very well may not have come back to beat
the atlanta falcons in that super bowl
uh five years ago
if
chris hogan was not such a clutch player
at the end of fourth quarter and in
overtime
where
tom brady and chris hogan
tormented the secondary of the atlanta
falcons with comeback routes and chris
hogan was the king of the comeback road
and i remember
asking brady remember that trip i made
to see brady up in montana mike a week
after that game
i go to see brady and i and i said
listen the one thing
that i'm so curious about
of the about this super bowl is i said
chris hogan and malcolm mitchell
became your go-to guys
in one of the biggest games of your life
i said i find that unbelievable
i said why do you go
to hogan and mitchell at such a huge
time and he goes peter
122 practices
and staying after practice
and drilling down on exactly where
they're going to be they know to the
foot
exactly how far downfield they have to
go i know exactly where they're going to
be it causes me to have comfort with
them and i don't care and i'm putting
words in brady's mouth but
his point was i don't care if they're
famous i don't care if they may never
have another moment
in the nfl you know it's like in
baseball sometimes the guy you never
heard of is the hero of the world series
everybody can have a moment and chris
hogan should wear that super bowl ring
proudly because in my opinion
i sincerely doubt that the patriots win
that super bowl without chris hogan on
the team
i remember chris hogan first becoming
aware of him 2012 hard knocks with the
dolphins remember his nickname
no
7-eleven always open
dolphins didn't make it there but
ultimately got his super bowl ring with
the patriots
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports